dust and that crops as far as the eye
can see this area only hundred and fifty
kilometers south of the capital addis
ababa is known as Ethiopia's breadbasket
last year however the rains didn't come
now farmers and cattle alike have
nothing to eat cut the fairy one fi'ty
i'm amanda persico didn't harvest
anything from this field but when the
crop started to grow the drought came
and then everything just withered away
now the cattle are dying and people are
also dying ooh I wonder woman and then
almost the entire crop in this area
failed which means that people are
almost completely reliant on food aid
they have also resorted to selling their
livestock which means that this drought
is likely to have a profound and
long-term impact on people's livelihoods
a few kilometres away the only irrigated
green patch of land around here belongs
to a large-scale investor who grows
animal feed for export but such
irrigation schemes are a distant
prospect for smallholder farmers who
account for eighty percent of the
population despite Ethiopia's
vulnerability to drought and climate
change little has been done to decrease
their reliance on unpredictable rainfall
oh and the character duty I have water
in this well but it's impossible to
irrigate large areas of land without a
pump and anyway we don't have the
experience and kissena metadata mean
zero the government is leading the
humanitarian response to the drought so
far it has contributed over 300 million
u.s. dollars of its own funds for
emergency water supply systems and food
distributions camino como la blanca the
government is doing its best to support
the people is kinder than waiting
probably every individual receives 15
kilograms of maize every month most of
the help is coming from the government
itself there was it down are gonna
nagari new rally vision research in
vision international organizations have
praised the government's response but
farmers complain of insufficient rations
unfair distribution and even corruption
farmer a dreamy haze uh says only two
people of her family of nine received
food aid in the morning the officials
took most of the food aid for themselves
and they gave little to others they take
take take everything that comes with
everything they'll need to supplement
the meager food rations otra has already
sold most of her cattle to buy food
while her remaining cows are losing
weight and value by the day unless more
aid comes through she fears her family
may soon run out of options